[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans sa hotte caddie avec ce matin notre
invité yvon serenus bonjour aux jeux ce
cas où vous êtes le président du
collectif des ouvriers et ouvrières
empoisonné par les pesticides ou
autrement appelée qu'aux adeptes alors
vous revenez d'une tournée on peut dire
ça comme ça
a paris vous êtes allé dans plusieurs
bureaux ministériels pour défendre
justement la cause des ouvriers et
ouvrières empoisonné par les pesticides
alors il y avez vous même dans la
délégation et puis vous étiez accompagné
de quatre personnes
on va les sites et patricia hamou tanda
rose marie marie luce cannelle
fourdrinier et marie-josèphe pinville
mais c'est bien ça alors parce que vous
considérez que l'empoisonnement massifs
perpétrés en toute connaissance de cause
notamment avec l' usage des pesticides
et en particulier le chlordécone est une
affaire qui concerne effectivement des
planteurs de bananes exportateur de
banane mais aussi l'état vous considérez
que l'état à ses responsabilités que
jusque là il n'a pas fait ce qu'il faut
en la matière alors dites-nous ils vont
serenus comment s'est passée cette ses
différentes visites à paris et qu'est ce
que vous en retirez finalement est-ce
que vous avez une note d'espoir après ça
et se déplace pas en france dès avant
notre départ on a bien signalé ce n'est
pas pour commander ni négocier on à ces
déplacements c'est pour qu'on met les
empoisonneurs devant leurs
responsabilités et
et chez nous et à foix souvent ils
disent que on savait pas mais là tout le
monde le sait on a omis notre mémorandum
qui est déterminant v responsables et
les onze points de revendications alors
vous dénoncez aussi quelque chose à face
à aux dénonciations que vous faites à
cette exigence de réparation quelque
sorte vous dire que l'état français
rétorque que le lien n'a pas été établi
entre les produits et les pathologies
puisqu'on parle notamment de nombre de
cancers important chez les ouvriers et
les ouvrières agricoles et vous
considérez que c'est une fuite de
responsabilité des auteurs de
l'empoisonnement y compris des services
de l'état oui si une fuite de
responsabilité mais c'est aimer puis
vers le peuple martiniquais
et puisque la quête que le collectif est
en train de mener auprès des ouvriers
agricoles là que tu nous as et fait la
démonstration que est la proie zone mans
massif des ouvriers agricoles et le
reste du peuple martiniquais est lié une
cocktail de pesticides qui est dans la
monoculture
alors on dit on parle de dons de l'état
français en général c'est à dire les
gouvernements qui ont précédé le
gouvernement actuel et le président de
la république
emmanuel macron mais vous dites
justement face aux nombreuses alertes
lancées depuis des années l'état
français a toujours fait la sourde
oreille et vous rajoutez selon vous
collectif des ouvriers et ouvrières
empoisonné par les pesticides que l'état
a usé de la répression pour ne pas nuire
aux intérêts des grands planteurs wii et
ds groupe l'auteur qui a empoisonné et
les hooligans coller le reste bêtement
une enquête d'une manière et
intentionnelle et aujourd'hui ça ils ont
dit les dossiers il sait des dossiers
qui sont mises
on ne peut pas l'utiliser dans un procès
notamment le dossier du rapport c'est
letchimy est versé pour protéger
toujours les hommes politiques et les
égouts planteurs de bananes qui a
empoisonné le peuple martiniquais et ses
quelques individus et qui sont il était
un bal organisé pour organiser ce crime
là et l'état continue à les protéger au
détriment du peuple en tunique est alors
évidemment tout le peuple martiniquais
et et est concerné on le sait mais plus
particulièrement ceux qui utilisaient
directement ses produits
on y revient et c'est ce que vous dites
parce que ce collectif ce qu'aux adeptes
collective des ouvriers et ouvrières
empoisonné par les pesticides
il a été créé on le rappelle en
septembre 2019 à l'initiative justement
d'ouvriers et d'ouvrières domaine
certains avaient dirigé la grève de 1974
dans les bananeraies et dans cette grève
là y'avait déjà parmi les revendications
l'arrêt de l' usage des pesticides
1 il faut le rappeler voilà et donc les
ouvriers et ouvrières agricoles il était
donc en première ligne dans la prise de
risque puisque quelques mots là-dessus
mais oui les oublier qu'elle est le
collectif a été créé à l'initiative d
ouvrir des cols les ouvriers qui étaient
dans la gamme de 1974
aujourd'hui ils sont âgés et des
personnes âgées et lee effectivement il
avait bien demandé la suppression
c'était le bon sens la suppression de
toutes les pesticides dans les
plantations de
la banane l'ananas 14 cette prise de
conscience de cela et aujourd'hui ils
sont toujours là au combat ou faire la
démonstration que effectivement l'un
poison demain à itier et d'une manière
et intentionnelle je rappelle que dans
les autres cas dit ce matin nous sommes
avec yvon c'est vénus le président du
collectif des ouvriers et ouvrières
empoisonné agricole empoisonné par les
pesticides
alors quand vous entendez ces derniers
temps évoquée par l'administration
judiciaire alors qu'il se réfère aux
textes de loi certes mais tout de même
quand vous entendez la justice une
évoqué une possible prescription des
faits en raison de leur ancienneté
oui et la justice mais disent et ce
qu'ils veulent parce que et toutes les
décisions
on est dans un pays colonisé toutes les
décisions qui est qui et la justice et
décide c'est le parquet de paris qui
donne dédié tiff nous rappeler que la
section d'ailleurs a été déplacée s'est
pas fait
ici ça a commencé et puis très vite on a
envoyé sa dans une juridiction
spécialisée à paris alors voilà donc qui
se disent que bon certains les faits
sont trop anciens remontent à trop
longtemps et donc en gros qu'il ya
prescription ça veut dire qu'on peut
plus juger mais attention c'est une
lecture contestées quand même par les
avocats de la partie civile c'est à dire
des plaignants y avait plusieurs
plaignants qui estiment que ses avocats
que de nouveaux faits sont apparus
depuis
oui oui il faut le aujourd'hui à léo
d'aujourd'hui et l'on parle de creo
déconne mais il ya une centaine de
molécules qui étaient étaient pendus
dans les échanges banane et aujourd'hui
encore il ya des nouvelles molécules qui
est très dangereux dans les chambres
banal notamment et les fongicides
oui donc ce que vous l'expliquer c'est
que peut-être effectivement il ya un
moment il ya une dizaine d'années
maintenant une bonne dizaine d'années on
a arrêté lusage du chlordécone de cette
molécule à travers un certain nombre de
produits mais justement ça a continué
jusqu'à encore maintenant donc et puis
et les les tonnes de pesticides qui
existait on s'en passer s'étonne de de
chlordécone et ils ont été enterrés
il y en a qui ont été jetés dans des
rivières ça s'est passé dans les années
2000 et ils nous disent il ya
prescription et jetés dans des rivières
et c'est qu'il n'y a pas de prescription
depuis 2000 voilà c'est bien ça c'est
bien pour ça d'ailleurs que ce collectif
s'appelle celui des ouvriers et
ouvrières agricoles empoisonné par les
pesticides et pas par la chlordécone
voilà tout simplement oui alors on
arriva à la fin de notre entretien ils
vont c'est vénus président de ce go
adeptes
vous après cette alors vous le faisiez
déjà mais peut-être encore plus après
cette tournée des bureaux ministériels à
paris vous en appelez à l'implication et
la mobilisation du peuple martiniquais
oui oui et il ya de celle de signaler et
ce mercredi et vous fait dans une
habitation
demain dans des quartiers ou d'amateurs
et qui est limité d'une habitation et de
bananes et conférence de presse et pour
qu'on puisse est expliqué et c'est ce
qui s'est passé dans le déplacement du
collectif par deux mais ça se passe à 15
heures où l'amateur cantier boucher
alors il ya autre chose
alors oui alesi et la mobilisation
c'est cette forme de lutte covan pour
déterminer la suite de notre travail est
aujourd'hui l'ensemble oui vous allez le
dire mais on a encore on a encore deux
minutes vous interpeller
je les dis le peuple donc l'opinion
publique en martinique mais aussi
partout dans le monde on voit que c'est
un problème d'ailleurs qui est évoqué
ici ou là c'est ça devient effectivement
international cette affaire donc vous
interpeller pour pousser à agir devant
toutes les juridictions internes
internationale alors interne à la france
internationale et cetera pour obtenir
réparation finalement de ce que vous
considérez comme un crime
d'empoisonnement et pour l'indemnisation
des victimes mais mais mais donc bien
sûr les membres des familles à se
mobiliser pour favoriser l' enquête mais
vous en vous interpeller aussi des
municipalités les syndicats les
associations de quartier demain vous
allez dans un quartier vous avez dit du
lamentin c'est saab auch est oui voilà
professionnels de santé juristes etc
écologistes les parlementaires voulaient
interpeller aussi vous leur demandez de
relayer vos revendications auprès des
institutions dont ils sont membres de
auprès du gouvernement français
donc voilà revendiquer la réparation et
impulser aussi et on termine là dessus
parce que vous voulez être aussi force
de propositions à partir de cette
expérience malheureuse qui
vous êtes arrivé voulait impulser un
développement économique alternatif
tournant le dos à la monoculture oui à
terminer l'actualisation c'est à nous la
question de la monoculture et n'est pas
viable pour la matinée c'est un modèle
économique qui est dépassée qui est gavé
de petits vente et de subventions au
détriment de l'agriculture martinez qui
peuvent nourrir le peuple martiniquais
et ça nous pénalise énormément
il faut arrêter avec ce modèle
économique oui c'est que c'est ce modèle
économique
on a utilisé parce qu'à l'époque on
disait qu'il fallait préserver les
emplois
on se souvient avait des crises la can
et cetera les gens travaillent dans la
banane et on disait ben oui mais il y
aura des centaines des milliers de
chômeurs en martinique donc il faut et
dépendre ce produit qui était contre le
charançon de la banane mais voilà parce
que s'il y avait une forte monoculture
oui jusqu'à maintenant oui et et et 7
pions modèle nous a entraînés dans les
autres écoles d'art et un double crime
d'un triple crime et la maladie là où
retraite qui est qui et que in web de
200 très fins elle préfère monter parce
que c'est ce qu'on voit c'est bien
souvent si les grands patrons békés qui
n'ont pas payé les les la retraite ils
ont pas déclaré les saisons ou agricoles
et à l'eau c'est dans ce cadre là qu'on
va se mobilier mobilisation le 27 mars
de 7 du mois prochain à vous approcher
et cette mobilisation on appelle tout le
peuple martiniquais à se mobiliser
autour des ouvriers agricoles pour la
répétition de ce seul set du 27 mars et
où en est une
et ça pour mettre un nouveau à
perspective la lutte du peuple en
tunique et passeur la lutte peu pratiqué
aujourd'hui c'est
la réparation de ce crime qui a été
commis par l'état et les groupes
l'auteur biquet et ils ont fait ça en
bande organisée et c'était délibéré ils
ont empoisonné la salle du peuple
martiniquais
c'est à suivre nous en reparlerons merci
ils vont serenus d'avoir répondu à nos
questions au ce matin bonne journée
bon courage mais à ses yeux à tous